Oh [Music]
beautiful day bit somber yeah
so quick video what's this this is a
journal or gratitude journal what
everyone will call it and I wanted to
make a video because this is the third
year now that I've kept a journal and I
think that it can benefit loads of
people if you don't have one so two main
reasons why or the benefits i've seen
from keeping a journal so firstly we're
all guilty of this and that's sort of
just holding on to how you're feeling
about something if you're angry it's
something or you're upset you're sad or
whatever it is you're holding on to it
and sometimes you feel like there's no
outlet besides maybe getting emotional
or having an argument with someone or
whatever and what this has really helped
me with is BL but there's something
about writing it down that is really
really powerful so when I felt maybe
some of those emotions and I felt sad
about certain things or upset or
whatever writing it down in this journal
really feels like you've got it off your
chest
and that helps a lot so that's the first
thing
secondly it's so easy to if you were to
say to me hisham what happened sort of
last year or what sort of how did last
year go I find that really hard it all
sort of just merges into one and what
this journal allows you to do is what
I've done for the last two years now is
as it is going on if you really wanted
to you could sort of take the time one
day a month to sort of just look through
your mum see how it's going for you see
where you can make improvements or what
you'll please we have all those sorts of
things but what's been really really
powerful is being able to look at my
whole year through sort of my entries
into my journal and you can get some
really really cool insights when you
have access to that
so with that as well it's so easy just
to forget sort of how far you've come
sometimes because you're you're thinking
about where you are now you didn't you
sometimes hard to really live or think
about where you was 12 months ago and
when you read passages from 12 months
ago you can sort of get into that
mindset of what you was that time or
what you as feeling and one I think
that's a great thing to be able to do to
go to make sure that you're sort of
taking the right steps and also as I
said some really really cool insights
you can get from reading your journal so
if you haven't got a journal I'd really
really recommend it there's no secret to
sort of what you have to write or
whatever just write how you feel right
how that day's gone maybe what you're
grateful for on that day and honestly
it's great it's a great great simple
tool to have and honestly I feel like a
lot of people could benefit from it
[Music]